there's a lyric from a Radiohead song
that perfectly captures the wistfulness
of lost love the wistfulness of what
could have been and might have been and
should have been if only and the lyric
goes like this I wish I could be who
wanted I wish I could
[Music]
and it's so perfectly captures that
bitter sweetness that aching sadness
that anguish of longing or what might
have been in you or I could have been
what we hoped each other would be for
one another right romantic love is a
projection right is an investment it's
an act of faith it's a leap of faith
it's an over inflation of the other
person it's raising a person up into a
pedestal it's turning a human being into
a god or a goddess and it's hoping that
by consummating with perfection itself
we will be raised above our animal
condition and made to be as gods outside
of time temporarily stepping off that
people-mover that's carrying everyone
else toward death right to fall in love
is to enter the forever box with
somebody else it's to live inside of a
pop song it's to stare in somebody's
eyes and feel so reassured that you want
to cry right it's the Christian knowing
your favorite songs
it's that sweeping swelling moment where
the strings your heartstrings are pulled
by the melody and you're carried
somewhere else when you exceed yourself
when you tear up well up when you're
crying because it feels so good to have
found something in which your your your
desires have been abolished by the
plenitude of their satisfaction it's
like only it doesn't get better
than this and you enter that halo you
enter that holy space that sacred holy
ground with someone it's an
intersubjective
life world
that's shaped like a heart cosmology of
to a universe shaped by two people a
lucid dream a fusion of cognition and
dream an altered state of consciousness
that you enter with this person now that
is a lot of pressure psychologist Ernest
Becker says as glorious as the song of
songs is when you're in love the
ravishment of romantic love it is
everything it is heaven on earth but can
a relationship bear the burden of
godhood with our gods eventually show
their clay feet will the cracks in this
benevolent perfect being you put on a
pedestal reveal your own cracks back to
you will you have to will the dream be
deflated by the unta logical reality of
death and transience and aging who can
bear love is aging who can bear the end
of the honeymoon phase it's a
fundamental problem with our wiring it's
called hedonic adaptation we can't
produce enough dopamine to stay in that
halo forever we will crash
we are bliss junkies we are hooked on
that state but can we raise the stage
Jamie wheel has talked about it David
Pearson the hedonistic imperative has
saying maybe the future will be to have
to rewire our neurology right to storm
heaven to become paradise engineers to
create a kind of consciousness that can
experience a rapture an absentee of love
forever when you marry someone you say I
will love you forever I want to feel
this way forever Miguel de Unamuno wrote
in a tragic sense of life eternity
eternity nothing is real that is not
forever
[Music]
so what do we do what the do we do
I'm still mourning I'm still grieving
for every love that I lost am I
supposed to get over that I didn't sign
up for these terms
[Music]